let's say I've got some subspace of RN
called V so V is a subspace is a
subspace of RN and let's say that I know
its basis let's say the set so I have a
bunch of let me make that bracket a
little nicer so let's say the set of the
vectors v1 v2 all the way to V K let's
say that this is equal to this is the
basis basis for V and just as a reminder
that means that these vectors both span
V and they are linearly independent you
can kind of say this is the minimum set
of vectors in RN that span V so if I
were do you ask you what the dimension
of V is the dimension of V that's just
the number of vectors you have in your
basis for the subspace so we have 1 2
when we count to k vectors so it is
equal to K now let's think about if we
can somehow figure out what the
dimension what the dimension of the
orthogonal complement of V can be and to
do that let's construct a matrix let's
construct a matrix whose vet column
vectors are these basis vectors so let's
construct a matrix a and let's say it
looks like this first column is V 1 this
first basis vector right there V 2 is
the second one and then you go all the
way to VK you go all the way to VK like
that just to make sure we remember the
dimensions we have K of these vectors so
we're going to have K columns and then
how many rows are we're going to have
well as a member of RN so these are all
going to have n entries in each of these
vectors it's going to be an N we're
going to have n rows and K columns it's
an N by K matrix now how can we express
what's another way of expressing the
subspace V well the basis for B or is or
via spanned by these basis vectors which
is the columns of these so if I talk
about the span so let me write it this B
is equal to the span of these guys v1 v2
all the way to VK
and that's just the same thing as the
column space of a right these are the
column vectors in the span of them
that's equal to that's equal to the
column space of a now I said a little
while ago we want to somehow relate to
the orthogonal complement of V what's
your thought on complement of the column
space of a your thuggin complementarity
of the column space of a I showed you I
think it was two or three videos ago
that the column space of a z' orthogonal
complement is equal to you could either
view it as the null space of a transpose
or another way you could call this is
the left null space of a this is
equivalent to the orthogonal complement
of the column space of a which is also
going to be equal to which is also since
this piece right here is the same thing
as V if you take a sore thumb compliment
that's the same thing as these
orthogonal complement so if we want to
figure out the orthogonal complement of
if we want to figure out the dimension
or view of the orthopod if we want to
figure out the dimensional of the
orthogonal complement of V we just need
to figure out the dimension of the left
null space of a or the null space of a
transpose let me write that down
so the dimension could you tongue-tied
sometimes the dimension of the
orthogonal complement of V is going to
be equal to the dimension of a transpose
or another way to think of it is
sorry not just the dimension of a
transpose the dimension of the null
space of a transpose the dimension of
the null space of a transpose and if you
have a good memory I don't use the word
a lot this thing is the nullity this is
the nullity of a transpose this is the
nullity of a transpose the dimension of
your null space is nullity the dimension
of your column space is your rank now
let's see what we can do here so let's
just take a transpose so you could just
imagine a transpose for a second so
a transpose I could just even draw it
out it's going to be a K it's going to
be a K by n matrix it's going to be a K
by n matrix it looks like this these
columns going to turn to rows here this
is going to be V 1 transpose V 2
transpose all the way down to VK
transpose its vectors so these are all
now row vectors so we know one thing we
know one relationship between the rank
and nullity of any matrix we know that
they're equal to the number of columns
we have we know that the rank so we know
that the rank we know that the rank of a
transpose plus the nullity the nullity
of a transpose is equal to the number of
columns of a transpose so we have n
columns each of these have n entries it
is equal to n we saw this a while ago
and if you want just a bit of a reminder
of where that comes from when you take a
if I wrote a transpose as a bunch of
column vectors which I can or maybe let
me take some other vector because I want
to just remind you where this why this
made sense if I take some vector B here
and it has got a bunch of column vectors
B 1 B 2 all the way to BN and I put it
into reduced row echelon form I put it
into reduced row echelon form you're
going to have some pivot columns and
some non-pivot columns so let's say this
is a pivot column you know I got a 1 and
a bunch of zeros let's say that this is
one of them and then let's say I got one
other one that's out it would be 0 there
let's see it's a 1 down there and
everything else is a non pivot column I
showed you in the last video that your
your basis for your column space is the
number of pivot columns you have so
these guys are pivot columns the
corresponding column vectors form a
basis for your column space it showed
you that in the last video and so if you
want to know the dimension of your
column space you just have to count
these things you just count these things
this was equal to the number of well for
this B's case the rank of B is just
equal to the number of pivot columns I
have now the nullity is the dimension of
your null space
done multiple problems where we found
the null space of matrices and every
time the dimension when you it's a bit
obvious and actually showed you this
proof it's related to the number of free
columns you have or non-pivot columns so
if you have no pivot columns then your
if you have no if all of your columns
are pivot columns and none of them have
free variables or associated with free
variables then your null space is going
to be trivial it's just going to have
the zero vector but the more free
variables you have the more
dimensionality your null space has so
the three columns correspond to the null
space and they form actually a basis for
your null space and because of that the
basis for your null space vectors plus
the basis for your column space is equal
to the total number of columns you had I
chose to do that to you in the past but
it's always good to remind ourselves
where things come from but this was just
a bit of a side I did this with a
separate vector B just to remind
ourselves where this thing right here
came from now in the last video in the
last video I showed you that the rank of
a transpose is the same thing as the
rank of a this is equal to this part
right here is the same thing as the rank
the rank of a I showed you that into the
last video when you transpose a matrix
it doesn't change its rank or it doesn't
change the dimension of its column space
so we can rewrite this statement right
here as the rank the rank of a plus the
nullity the nullity of a transpose is
equal to n and the rank of a is the same
thing as the dimension of the column
space of a and then the nullity of a
transpose is the same thing as the
dimension of the null space of a
transpose that's just the definition of
Knology they're going to be equal to n
and what's the dimension what's the
column space of a the column space of a
that's what's spanned by these vectors
right here which were the basis for V so
this is the same thing as the dimension
of V the column space of a is the same
thing as the dimension of my subspace V
that I started this video with and what
is the null space of a transpose the
null space of a transpose we saw already
that's
that's the orthogonal complement of V so
I could write this as plus the dimension
of the orthogonal complement of V is
equal to n and that's the result we
wanted if V is a subspace of RN so V
subspace subspace of R n that n is the
same thing as that n then the dimension
of V plus the orthogonal of the
orthogonal complement of V is going to
be equal to n